In 1912, the Titanic set off for her maiden
voyage across the Atlantic Ocean.
The ship’s builders were convinced that
even in the most disastrous collision at sea,
the ship could float for two to three days,
enough time for nearby ships to come to its rescue.
But on April 14th, the Titanic struck a massive
iceberg and in just three short hours the ship had sunk.
The collision fractured the ship’s hull,
cracking it like a china plate, as well as
shearing off the rivets holding it in place.
And as we all know, it was an absolute disaster.
One of our most important tasks as engineers
is to try and avert catastrophes like these.
You see, when it comes to structures, tools
and equipment, we need to make sure they’re
made of the right stuff.
That means taking a closer look at the materials
they’re made of.
So this episode is really going to test your,
uh mettle.
[Theme Music]
If a material exists, there’s a pretty good
chance an engineer has thought about using
it at some point.
As far back as two and a half million years ago, early
humans were using the materials around them, primarily
stone and wood, to build tools like hammers and axes.
These days, we’ve developed totally new
materials.
There’s aerogel, for example, which is an
ultra-light substance that can withstand high
temperatures.
Not to mention graphene, a one-atom-thick sheet
of carbon atoms that’s stronger than steel and
superb at conducting heat and electricity.
While those advanced materials might be used more
widely in the future, today, most materials that engineers
work with can be categorized into three groups.
Metals and their alloys; ceramics and glass;
and polymers.
Which material is best suited for a job depends
on its properties, and how those properties
affect it in practice.
More specifically, whatever we’re using, it’s
vital to know the material’s mechanical properties.
Mechanical properties relate to how a material’s
shape changes when a force is applied to it.
To make better sense of this, it helps to
have a concrete example in mind.
But we’re not actually going to use concrete.
At least not yet.
Instead, we’ll consider a steel beam, like
the kind widely used in civil engineering
and construction.
Of course, we could make beams out of all
kinds of materials, and the resulting beams would
have different properties.
But no matter what you’re making them
out of, there’s one important thing to know:
no material is perfectly rigid.
As long as you apply a large enough force,
a beam will deform and change shape, even
if only internally.
Some things you encounter in everyday life
might seem totally rigid because the change
in shape is so small.
But when that stops being the case, it can
have dramatic consequences.
Something that all engineers aim to avoid
is failure .
Not in the sense of whether or not you do
things exactly right all the time.
Even engineers aren’t perfect, and sometimes
we get things a little wrong.
It’s all part of the learning process.
When it comes to materials, the word ‘failure’
describes the point at which a material breaks.
And unlike messing up a few problems on
your math homework, this is the kind of failure
that isn’t worth the learning opportunity!
In a system like a car, where everything depends
on the structural integrity of the materials, the
outcome could be fatal.
So to prevent critically dangerous situations,
engineers characterize a material’s mechanical
properties so they can prevent it from failing.
If you’re using a beam to construct a building,
those properties are crucial for keeping the
structure standing tall.
This is where stress comes in.
We touched on what stress means in an engineering
context when we looked at fluids: it’s the force
applied over a particular area of the material.
We can apply this type of stress to our beam
in three distinct ways:
There’s compressive stress, which pushes
in on the ends of a material.
Then there’s tensile stress, which stretches
and potentially elongates it.
And finally, there’s shear stress, where
you push sideways on a material in opposite
directions.
To measure the effects of this stress on our
beam, we look at its strain.
Strain is how much the beam’s length changes
in a particular direction.
When we were discussing stresses on liquids, the
level of deformity was linked to the liquid’s viscosity:
how easily it flowed in response to pressure.
In a materials context, the level of deformity
is a little more complicated.
But like so many things in engineering, visualizing
it as a graph can help.
Let’s take the beam and put it in an extensometer, a piece of equipment with an awesome name that will apply tensile strength to the beam and measure its strain.
To graph what’s happening, we’ll put the
level of stress we’re applying, represented by
the greek letter ‘sigma,’ on the vertical axis.
Then we’ll put the strain on the horizontal
axis.
When the stress we’re applying is perpendicular
to the ends of the beam, as in the extensometer,
the resulting change in length is called the
normal strain.
That’s represented with the letter ‘epsilon.’
As we increase the stress on the object, the
material will begin to display signs of strain,
changing its length.
The amount of stress a material is subjected to before
it undergoes a particular amount of strain –
in other words, the slope of the line – is
known as the modulus of elasticity.
That quantity is a measure of how resistant
our material is to bending and stretching.
The closer the line is to vertical, the higher
the modulus.
To make sense of the units here, stress is
measured in gigapascals because it’s a force
applied over an area,
which gives it the same dimensions as pressure.
Strain, meanwhile, is a ratio of two lengths,
so it’s a dimensionless quantity – it has no units.
Putting that all together, the modulus of
elasticity has units of gigapascals.
But what does the modulus actually mean?
Let’s compare beams made of two different
materials: rubber and concrete.
Rubber has a modulus of elasticity of just 0.01
gigapascals, while concrete has a modulus of 30.
That means for a given amount of stress applied
to each material, the rubber will have a proportional
change in length 3,000 times that of the concrete!
That’s not surprising, right?
We know it’s easier to stretch rubber than
concrete.
So the modulus of elasticity, which you can
measure from the stress-strain diagram,
gives you an idea of how much the material
resists a change in shape under an applied stress.
For example, in units of gigapascals, the
modulus of glass is around 50, while brass
is around 100.
Steel is higher still, at around 200, while
diamond clocks in at a whopping 1,220 gigapascals!
So far, all the lines on the stress-strain
diagram have been straight, with constant slopes.
But as you apply even more stress, that relationship
breaks down, and the material will begin to deform and
stretch along its cross section as well as its length.
We call that point the yield stress.
For example, apply enough tensile strength to a bar
of clay and eventually it gets thinner in the middle as it
stretches to meet the demands of high tensile stress.
Finally, if we apply enough tensile stress, the
material breaks apart entirely and undergoes failure.
And the exact same thing can happen to our
steel beam, too!
The stress-strain curve tells you about another
important property for avoiding failure and determining
a material’s suitability: its toughness.
A material’s toughness is the amount of
energy it can absorb before it undergoes failure.
On our diagram, that’s represented by the
total area under the curve for the material,
from the origin to the failure point.
If you know a bit of calculus, you’ll recognise
this as the integral of the stress-strain curve.
Toughness isn’t the same as strength, though!
A material might be very strong, with a very
high modulus of elasticity, but break after only
a small amount of strain.
On the other hand, a material might be able
to strain a long distance without breaking,
but have a very low modulus of elasticity,
like Play-Doh.
Toughness is a balance between the two.
And while a tough material might be useful
for making the foundations of a building,
in other applications it might be something
you want to avoid!
For example, by adding carbon to the steel
beam, you can give it a greater yield stress.
It barely deforms under a single impact, but
that also makes it more brittle.
Meanwhile, low carbon steel has a low modulus
of elasticity, it will deform much more quickly
because it has a low yield stress, but that
makes it more ductile, so it’s more useful
for shaping and welding.
But neither of those options maximizes the
toughness of steel!
Toughness would be finding the middle ground
where you maximize the area under the curve,
so the steel is able to absorb as much energy
as possible before fracturing.
A measurement that comes in handy for measuring
this is the Charpy impact test,
which tells us the toughness of our material by
whacking it with a hammer.
No, seriously.
The Charpy test measures toughness by taking
a small sample of material and striking it with a
hammer on a pendulum and trying to break it.
The height you drop the hammer from and
the height that the hammer swings up to after
smashing through the material
can determine how much energy the
hammer lost breaking the sample.
And that tells you how tough the material
is.
While not all material tests are quite as
fun to perform,
there are lots of different mechanical properties to
consider in materials that could make them totally
great for the job at hand or just completely useless.
For example, there’s hardness, which is
how much your material deforms in a particular
location – that is, how easily you can dent it.
Measuring hardness is simple enough: you use
a device called an indenter to apply a localized load
to your material and see how much it gets dented.
Pretty straightforward!
Another mechanical property which can be a
good or a bad thing, depending on the situation,
is creep strength.
Which thankfully has nothing to do with the
Minecraft monster.
Creep strength is how much a material resists
deforming or, to use the engineering term, resists creep
under long term stress or extreme temperatures.
In some cases, a low creep is a good thing.
In the blades of a propellor, too much creep
could elongate the blades and make them hit
the casing, damaging them.
But in a concrete structure, some amount
of creep can be useful since it prevents the
concrete from cracking outright.
There’s also fatigue strength, which measures
how many times a material can endure a certain
amount of stress before it fails.
Sometimes even applying small loads of stress
well below the yield stress still leaves tiny impacts,
like microscopic cracks in the material.
If that small amount of stress is applied
repetitively, the cracks can deepen and spread in
the material until they eventually cause fracture.
As you’d expect, a material might be able
handle lots of little bits of stress applied
to it over time before it fractures.
But it might only survive failure under a
few large stresses.
The fatigue strength is the highest possible
stress a material can withstand a given number
of times before undergoing failure.
Of course, hardness, creep strength, and fatigue
strength are just some of a material’s mechanical
properties.
We might also need to consider how the surface
of our chosen material reacts with its environment,
how much it costs to produce and obtain, and
even what it looks like.
And while all of those are important, it isn’t
much use considering those other properties
until you’re sure the material is mechanically
up to the task of handling the stresses and
strains the world is gonna throw its way.
And knowing about the the strengths of the
materials you use will add to your strengths
as an engineer.
In this episode, we’ve started considering
the materials that are used in engineering.
We looked at mechanical properties of materials,
which describe how much strain a material undergoes
given a certain amount of stress.
From stress-strain diagrams, we found useful
properties that could be measured like the
modulus of elasticity and toughness,
and described other material properties
like hardness, creep strength, and fatigue
strength.
Next time, we’ll get into the real substance
of things and discuss the materials themselves
in a bit more depth,
starting with what makes a metal a metal.
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
If you have a couple minutes, we have some
homework for you because PBS Digital Studios
is conducting its annual survey,
which gives us a chance to hear from you
and helps us make some big decisions.
Plus, 25 random people will win a PBSDS t-shirt.
Head on over to the link in the description.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and this
episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.